Wall Street opens this morning after
hitting a new milestone the Dow Jones
Industrial Average soared past 23,000
yesterday for the first time it closed
just below that mark gaining 40 points
for the day since the start of 2017 the
Dow has climbed more than 3,000 points
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with what's behind
the record-breaking surge Jill good
morning so what are some of the factors
well I think the first thing is that the
economy is growing and the global
economy is growing and that may have a
bigger factor this year because the rest
of the world has caught up to the US we
also know that corporate profits are
doing quite well they've done quite well
for the last six months or so and that's
been helpful and we're in a low interest
rate environment you put those three
things together you get a surging market
and it's a continuation of this strong
bull market it is now the second longest
bull market on record well the
president's taking credit for the surge
can he well I think partially I mean
let's let's think about this we've got a
bull market it started back in March of
2009 so the first 92 months of the bull
market that occurred under President
Obama the most recent 11 months under
President Trump now the reality is when
he was first elected people thought the
markets gonna go up we're gonna get
infrastructure we're gonna spending
we're gonna get tax reform we're gonna
get regulatory reform of those three
we've gotten a little bit of regulatory
reform that's it so I still think the
fundamentals are what's driving the
market right now not so much what the
Trump administration is doing although
they are saying they will do something
that's that how worried are you about
how long this can last I'm always
worried tomorrow marks the 30th
anniversary of the crash of 1987 and I
hate to admit it but I was a young pup
trader that month and it was scary that
day the stock market dropped by 22% in
one session that is as if the Dow
dropped 5,000 points or more right now
that was caused by a confluence of
various things but reality is those
things are not cret present now they
could always happen it's good to be
defensive don't take on too much risk
and yet we recovered from that and will
from the next correct well yes but we
don't want have to go through it again
Phil thank you thank you very much